If you look at the shadows in this scene
you can see they're completely black.
This is typically not
what reality looks like.
As an example, the floor under your
desk is typically not completely black
even if no light from any specific
lamp is hitting it directly.
The classic hack for
working around completely black
shadows is the flat ambient light.
It basically means adding
a constant color to all pixels.
As you can see, the shadows are no
longer black but still they look flat.
As an example, you can't even see
where the edge between the wall and
the floor is in the shadow.
Having a constant color like this
doesn't simulate how light behaves in
reality.
You wouldn't be able to buy a lamp
like behaving like this at Ikea.
Let's see if we can do better.
So how do light behave in real life?
When you look at the point in the scene,
what is it you actually see?
It's the light from the light source
being reflected into your eyes.
But only a fraction of the light
reflected from the surface
is actually going into your eyes.
This bounced or indirect light is a big
contribution of light in a scene.
Let's enable simulation of it.
Now the shadows looks
much more interesting.
What's really going on is that light
hitting a surface is being reflected
back into the scene.
This light can then be
reflected back again and again.
Since the walls absorb
light with each bounce,
each secondary bounce is
weaker than the previous one.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
You can also see how the light hitting
the red wall is being reflected back
into the scene as red light.
This is what we call color bleeding and
it happens because the red wall absorbs
all but the red component of
the light bouncing off it.
To properly simulate
indirect lighting for
complex scenes can be
very time consuming.
Single frames of high quality rendering
can literally take hours and even days.
This wraps up the ambient and
indirect like part.
Thanks for listening.